Simplifica 25 "a" cúbica,
"a" cúbica elevado al cubo,
"b" cuadrada dividido entre
"5a" cuadrada"b", "b" cuadrada.
Esto lo podemos hacer de diversas maneras, simplificando distintas cosas.
Lo que yo quiero hacer es simplificar "a" cúbica elevado al cubo,
para esto vamos a usar esa propiedad de los exponentes que nos dice
que "a" cúbica elevada al cubo,
es lo mismo que "a" elevada a la 3 por 3.
Así es que esto es...
déjame moverme un poco hacia arriba...
esto es lo mismo que "a" elevada a la potencia 3 por 3,
que es igual a "a" elevada a la novena potencia.
Ahora,
podemos simplificar "b" por "b" cuadrada.
Vamos a simplificar este producto
de "b" por "b" cuadrada.
Recuerda cuando tienes "b"
es  como si tuvieras "b" elevado a la 1,
para calcular "b" a la 1 por "b" cuadrada,
tenemos que sumar los exponentes.
Así que "b" a la 1 por "b" cuadrada es igual a
"b" elevada a la 1 más 2, que es igual a "b" cúbica.
Finalmente de lo que podemos simplificar
a simple vista, tenemos aquí 25 entre 5,
25 entre 5 es igual a 5,
ó si quieres... o sacando quinta,
25 nos da 5, sacando quinta a 5 nos da 1.
Estamos dividiendo tanto el numerador como el denominador entre 5.
Ahora ya hemos simplificado nuestra expresión a 5,
que multiplica a "a" a la novena,
que multiplica a "b" cuadrada
y eso dividido entre "a" cuadrada
que multiplica a "b" cúbica...
que multiplica "b" cúbica.
Ahora podemos usar
la propiedad para el cociente de exponentes.
Tenemos "a" a la novena entre "a" cuadrada...
déjame usar otro color...
"a" a la novena
entre "a" cuadrada
y eso se simplifica
como vamos a escribirlo acá abajo.
"a" a la novena entre "a" cuadrada,
es igual "a" a la 9 menos 2
y eso nos da igual a "a",
elevada a la séptima potencia.
Ahora también tenemos "b" cuadrada sobre "b" cúbica, esto se pone interesante,
porque esto es entonces "b" cuadrada sobre "b" cúbica es igual a "b" elevado a la 2 - 3,
y esto es igual a "b" elevada a la potencia -1,
y eso por lo pronto lo vamos a dejar así.
Y ahora ya hemos simplificado nuestra expresión a 5
que multiplica a "a" a la séptima.
Como obtuvimos aquí, "a" a la séptima
y esto que multiplica lo que hicimos aquí con las "b"
que es "b" a la -1.
Ahora, podríamos haber dejado la expresión así,
ya está simplificada,
sin embargo no nos gusta este exponente -1,
así es que vamos a aplicar la siguiente propiedad.
"b" a la -1 es igual a 1 entre "b",
por lo cual, la expresión queda finalmente como
nuestro coeficiente 5 que multiplica a
"a" séptima
y eso que se multiplica por 1 entre "b",
o lo que es lo mismo dividido entre "b"
que como vimos es equivalente a "b" a la -1.
Y así hemos concluido.